okay everybody in our first story adam
mossari says instagram is taking a break
on their project instagram for kids uh
so we talked about this on episode 1284
um when we were talking about wall
street journals facebook files that is
the moniker given to
uh a bunch of leaked internal research
and presentations and all kinds of
materials coming out of facebook over
the last couple of weeks and we also
talked about how the leaker is probably
going to
uncloak themselves
this is i think
if you haven't seen the movie the
insider uh michael mann uh
with russell crowe i think it's russell
crowe's greatest performance after
gladiator but it's probably tied in
terms of i mean two different types of
people two different types of heroes
but really
absolutely go watch the insider because
it's about the whistleblower in uh the
tobacco industry and how hard it is to
be a whistleblower this whistleblower i
think is going to go down in history as
one of the most important people of this
era
potentially because the these studies
are so damning and i think it's going to
result in facebook people resigning
um and maybe lawsuits in any any number
of um
events that will be considered a turning
point in our industry the leaked studies
included a 2019 slide from facebook's
internal research they do internal
research they fund research which claim
that instagram makes quote body images
worse for one in three teen girls
amongst other
negative health impacts that we know
about social media
and the leaker is in all likelihood from
inside of the integrity department kid
you're not facebook has an integrity
department
fate loves irony and uh the lead
reporter from the wall street journal on
the facebook file says that many
employees in the integrity department
have been very fed up because
they've been proposing solutions and
they feel like they're being ignored
sound familiar go watch the movie the
insider same thing happened in big
tobacco and there was also a similar
cover-up inside of cars uh with airbags
and seatbelts yeah ralph nader's book
unsafe at any speed where he talked
about the automobile industry i've never
actually read the book but that would be
a good one to look at
so we have this long history of
corporations maybe not doing what's in
the best interest of the public because
it would have such a bad impact on their
growth and the personal wealth of
individuals inside companies so here is
adam mosari i don't know when adam
joined facebook and instagram but you
know you can be certain that if he's
running instagram he's making millions
and millions of dollars a year uh you
know maybe 10 20 million dollars at the
end of the day with the value of all the
stock options and what they'll
eventually become worth
so he came on nbc's today show this
morning uh and he announced that
instagram we'd be putting instagram for
kids project on hold
really uh due to all this public outcry
one minute clip i'll talk to you on the
other side
you guys have had this research you've
had this information for for some time
why not do some of this sooner
so we've actually been working on a lot
of this for years now we do this
research to shed light on problems
that's the whole point of the research
is why i'm actually proud that we do
that kind of work that work has inspired
lots of interesting product changes for
instance
we announced a couple years ago we
wanted to lead on the issue of online
bullying yeah and the research we did
when we asked kids and teens why they
didn't
block people who were harassing them on
instagram was that they were worried
about fear of retribution because they
have to see these kids in school and
also they needed to track what their
what was being said about them so that
inspired the restrict feature which we
launched a few years ago so over the
years we were constantly doing this
research both internally and externally
and using it to inspire changes to the
product
okay so he said a whole bunch of nothing
there i mean great they they studied
bullying uh but really
didn't answer the question did he uh you
know the question is really like
why is this taking so much time and why
would you
ever even consider doing a kids app so
uh instead of doing instagram for kids
missouri says that they're going to
focus on making more parental controls
on instagrams or an app
which is what i said last week you know
no kid should be on there and parents
should have access to their kids
instagrams uh in a you know
r packed which is an app uh that some
friends of mine had told me about where
you make an agreement with your kids hey
i'll let you use instagram but here are
the rules i need to see what you're
doing there when you post an image i
want to approve it first or i want to be
able to see your dms you know that
the idea that you would see dms for an
adult would be spying on each other but
with a kid it's kind of training wheels
right you don't let a bunch of kids go
to the mall when they're 10 years old
without supervision i mean my parents
did but it was a different era you know
you probably want to have some amount of
supervision at a party where kids can
interact on their own in the backyard or
at a park but you're kind of off to the
side watching them there's some
agreement here
that kids can make with their parents
and so i think that that's ultimately
where this goes is that
kids who are
just like when they drive a car you know
if you have gps in your car or a speed
limiter
for a child who is now 16 or 17 years
old to becoming a young adult and they
want to drive the car they're giving up
their privacy of location they're giving
up the freedom to speed
in exchange for getting the privilege of
driving the car kind of there's an
analogy here i think for social media as
well you want to use social media
there's going to have to be some
guardrails you only can drive during the
day you can't drive at night you can't
drive on the highway you have to be
within 30 miles of the house you get the
idea so um
sorry gave an interesting answer here uh
when asked about the uh leech research
75 seconds i'll talk to the other side
let's talk about the kids for a second
because according to your own research
as i understand it a third roughly a
third of teenage girls who said when
they felt bad about their bodies
instagram made them feel worse how do we
fix that
so i don't believe that's exactly what
the research said but i do want to be
very clear that if anybody
leaves using instagram feeling worse
about themselves that's an important
issue that we need to take seriously and
then we need to figure out how to
address and so we have a number of ideas
in the world of body image and negative
social comparison last week we announced
that we were working on nudges the idea
that if you're going very deep in one
topic we might nudge you to try another
topic and another project that we call
take a break the idea being that you
could put your instagram on pause for a
period of time if you're in a moment of
vulnerability maybe you're going through
a breakup or you just switched high
schools
so
i i know the details are being worked
out but this take a break idea i mean
how will that work when we see that in
our feeds
so the way it would work is that your
instagram your account your profile how
you show up would essentially be on
pause so
the specific details were still working
through but you would be
you would the idea is that you wouldn't
have to worry about people talking about
you addressing you commenting on your
content while you were on a break you
would basically be able to leave and
then come back and pick up exactly where
you left off
this is exactly what i said last week
right there should be timeouts on social
media you press a button and
it says i don't want anybody to view my
profile
essentially like your autoresponder on
email tells people hey listen i'm not
here
i'm don't expect a response imagine you
came to my social media profile i did
this over the summer and i said hey i'm
taking a twitter break because i have to
focus on the book and i just the last
week i got sucked back in but i'm going
to take another break
because i i keep getting pulled back in
but the ability to press a button say i
want to be on break for the next 30 days
or indefinitely
then no comments come in no likes come
in and maybe you can't see my photos
maybe i'm ghosted basically says hey
jason will be back on this date if you
do that what that would do is let give
people permission to not feel compelled
to check it that's a great idea that's
why i suggested it last week
and i think it's probably a fairly
obvious one right i think probably all
of us
take social media breaks but
incorporating it into the product will
be great
listen right now linkedin is going to
give you a hundred dollar credit towards
your first ad campaign i want you to go
to linkedin.com
this week in startups and get that
hyundy right now now why would you use
linkedin marketing
high quality leads we all need leads
we're all running businesses here my
leads startup founders your leads might
be sas enterprise it might be cfos it
might be cmos it might be ctos who knows
everybody's got a different product but
everybody is on linkedin we all know
that because we all use linkedin every
single day so if you're planning a
launch a new campaign you know your
audience your team is excited and
everything is going according to plan
we've all been there except you have
that one thought in the back your head
how can i be sure that my acquisition
campaign will drive high impact leads
for my sales team well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your message
reaches people who are ready to engage
you linkedin equals business business
equals linkedin you know this it's very
simple so with 30 million companies
engaging and over 71 of professionals
using linkedin to inform their business
decisions
linkedin can help bring your growth to
the next level
don't wait to start achieving your brand
and lead gen goals get a 100 ad credit
towards your first linkedin campaign at
linkedin.com
this week in startups once again
linkedin.com slash this week in startups
for the hyundy no spaces no dashes and
terms and conditions apply because
they're giving you a handy